it sort of happens what happens though
you know it's not the kind of thing you
can force well it looks like Ben Affleck
and Ana de Armas don't have to force
anything
the 47 year old actor and the 31 year
old actress were first linked earlier
this month after they were spotted
looking cozy in Cuba together now a
source tells ET that they're having fun
and keeping things exciting Ben and Anna
have been dating for a few weeks and are
enjoying each other's company the couple
met while filming deep water in
Louisiana and instantly had a connection
according to the source Ana is also
supportive of Ben's sobriety the idea
that life gets better that you can get
better that you can overcome your
obstacles is a really important one to
me something he's been open about while
promoting his latest flick the way back
where he plays a basketball coach
struggling with addiction I would say it
was bold taking on a project that you
know your character has struggles with
issues that you deal with personally so
was that something that influenced you
and taking on this role yeah I mean you
know it's an interesting question
because I feel a little bit awkward sort
of taking credit for me never been so
many alcoholics who played alcoholics in
the history of the movie business you
know many of whom are quite public about
it like and talked about it and I knew
that you know in this day and age of
sort of like celebrities personal lives
becoming news stories those are
questions that I was gonna have to kind
of answer anyway so what was interesting
for me was to be able to define the
story myself the way I see it which is
really one of hope quote Ben is sober
and in a really good place and honor
respects him for the process he's going
through Ben and Anna are still early
into their relationship but it's been
fun and exciting for both the two have
been spending a lot of time together
going on coffee runs showing PDA in
Costa Rica and on Saturday the two were
spotted strolling arm in arm during a
morning walk then
even got a little flirty on Instagram
asking for photo cred in the common
of this post just last month been told
et what he's looking for in his next
relationship oh I don't know I think a
trust and care and mutual respect and
you know all the sort of usual stuff but
but I think that's a big part of what
makes life satisfying and interesting
you know so obviously like everybody
it's something that I'm that I'm
interested in and you know it sort of
happens what happens though you know
it's not the kind of thing you can you
give force
[Music]